-How are you, Michael?
-I'm good.
I mean, it was a rough summer,
but, you know,
now we're back to school.
Not bad.
-Yeah, it's not bad to try
to bring a little semblanc
of normalcy into our lives
A thing that was very abnormal
for me is when we met.
We met on an Amtrak train
in 2011.
We were both on our way
to that White House
Correspondence Dinner.
-I remember.
I remember meeting you.
That was a great joy,
because I'm a fan.
But what an epic night that was.
What a crazy --
You called out, you shot down --
You called out Donald Trump.
And then --
And then, your follow-up was
Obama calling down Donald Trump.
And who might have guessed
where that would have gone
-I know.
It would have been a lot nicer
if it had just been
a footnote of history
instead of a tipping point
[ Laughing ]
-Exactly. I mean,
that's the point where he was --
So, he started as, what,
a failed Midtown
real-estate developer,
then became
a successful reality-TV star
which is where this happened
And now we get this bloviating
puff adder, sack of lies.
What next?
-It is --
It's a certainly an interestin
progression his career
has taken.
You -- You're obviously --
I think we share
a lack of fandom
for the current president.
And you're actually
taking steps with vote.org
and, really --
I guess it's sort of --
a bit of an online
art installation?
Is that a safe way
to describe planyourvote.org
-Planyourvote --
yeah, planyourvote.org
was set up through vote.org,
and it's working with artist
to make sure that people
get out to vote
and that people plan what
they have to do in their city,
in their region, in their stat
to be able to vote.
-And were you always passionat
about politics,
or was it something that you
came to later in life?
-You know, it started, really,
with the band,
with my former band, R.E.M
When we were travelling
outside of the country,
we sudden-- this is during
the Reagan years.
And we suddenly, in Europe
were representative of America
and people were saying --
You know,
we're there to play a show
and a completely unknown band,
and people were like,
"What the [bleep]
are you people thinking?
What are you doing over there?
And so we had to, in a way
kind of politicize ourselves
and educate ourselves
about who we are --
who we are
to the rest of the world
and who we are to ourselves.
-I would at least hope,
in most foreign countries,
they would assume that R.E.M
wasn't necessarily
a Reagan band.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, well, we weren't making
a whole lot of sense back then
Neither was he,
but people figured out
pretty quickly
that we were not giant fan
of that particular
administration.
-You talk about not making
a lot of sense early on,
and I don't know
if I'd agree with that.
But you -- again, you've had
an interesting progression
and now
you're writing solo music.
It must be
a very strange experience,
having worked with a band
for so long.
How have you found it?
-Well, I had -- for 32 years
through R.E.M., I had, you know,
for me, the greatest -- th
greatest possible co-writers
working on
and composing all the music,
and then my job was to listen to
what they did and respond to it.
I'm now composing myself,
and it's the first time in m
life that I've written music
And I found it
weirdly satisfying.
I can't say that it sounds
very much like R.E.M.,
but I'm really happy
with where it's gone.
And I've been able to,
because of R.E.M.
and because of all the fan
across the years,
I'm able to take
all the money that I make
for the first year
of the release of every single
that I'm putting out
as a solo artist
and donate it or dedicate it
to organizations and movements
that I feel very strongly about,
like Pathway to Paris,
Extinction Rebellion.
The Equal Just--
The Equal Justice Initiative
who have that incredible
Legacy Museum down in Alabama.
And, so, that feels good.
I feel like, as an activist,
I'm kind of doing my part.
I'm trying to.
-You know, I feel like
some artists
found this time difficult,
insofar as being creative.
How was it for you?
-Extremely difficult.
I learned that I'm a better cook
than I thought I was.
I've learned that I'm better
on my own
than I ever thought I could be
I'm comfortable with mysel
when I'm alone.
But it's been a very --
It's been a very hard year
for everyone, I think.
There's no "I think" about it.
It's been --
This has been perhaps the most
difficult year of my long life
-One of the most difficult
things that happened, obviously,
were people -- you know,
many people losing those
that were dear to them,
loved ones.
And we have --
had a friend in common
who passed away
very sadly, Hal Willner.
I knew Hal
from working with him at "SNL.
You knew him a lot better.
I will say,
he's one of those people that --
very selfishly,
one of my first thoughts was
"I just wish
I had talked to him more.
I just wish I'd spent
more time with him,
because Hal was someone who --
his wisdom and his kindnes
will be very hard to replace
-I found some, um --
I found some text messages
that I didn't return from him.
You -- you can't fathom
that type of loss
until it's happened that
dramatically and unexpectedly.
I will say -- I'm sorry.
I really loved that guy a lot.
Paid me the greatest complimen
I've ever been paid in my life
and I will never forget that
for my whole life.
But Hal and I were
working on a project
that hasn't come out yet.
And, so, the last thing
that we did together
is a tribute to his best friend,
I think, Lou Reed.
So, that will be released
probably very soon
and most certainly
as a tribute to his genius
-I also remember
one or two compliments from Hal,
and the thing
that you could take to the ban
is that he meant it,
because there was no way
he would waste his time
lying about a piece of art
-Yeah.
He was the great champion
of the people
that are easily overlooked
the artists who are not so eas
to put into categories.
And he championed people
like myself
and other people
who haven't had the succes
that I've had, his entire life
And, so, there's a --
there's a --
there's a powerful
and strong legacy there.
-Well, thank you so much
for sharing that.
I could talk about Hal all day
I could talk to you all day.
Thank you so much
for being here, Michael.
I really appreciate it.
-Seth, thanks for having me,
and stay strong.
-Will do.
-Vote. Vote. Vote.
-Agreed.
Agreed on all counts.